[Musique]
alors voilà un objet tout à fait typique
du togo j'ai fabriqué en ébène les
bennes est un bois qui pousse très
lentement et qui est très dur et donc
les sculptures sont difficiles une
sculpture qu'annick carrare elizabeth au
lion proposeront à la vente ce week end
ses deux saint quentinois sont bénévoles
à avenir togo une association créée en
1995 par une pasteure mana et vous
soutenir l'action du cast du centre
d'action sociale au togo qui accueille
des enfants abandonnés handicap etc
c'est de les loger de les nourrir de
veiller à leur santé de scolariser quand
ils grandissent et de les accompagner
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient un métier entre
les mains quoi qui ce qu'ils aient
acquis leur indépendance à venir togo
est l'une des trois associations
présentes elle sera au marché solidaire
de saint quentin en yvelines avec
amnesty international et artisans du
monde
les 14 et 15 décembre prochains la
commanderie propose un temps fort lors
de son noël décalé il faut penser aux
autres parce que c'est peut-être notre
côté décalé où on a envie de paille
forcément être dans la surconsommation
dans les déchets on veut être
responsable en fait solidaire un marché
solidaire compliquée par un marché de
créateurs saint quentinois grâce auquel
le pied du sapin devrait se trouver bien
garni